اصلا دخلت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لافغانستان للتخلص من هذه القياده الدينيه
للمعاقبتها على الاحداث الارهابيه ب 2001
ولكنها لم تكن الحاله الوحيده لخروج
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه راينا خروجها
من افغانستان وراينا خروجها من الشرق
الاوسط راينا خروجها من العراق بهذه
الطريقه بعد ان تقريبا سلمت العراق لايران
الا ترى ان ذلك بعث الرساله الخاطئه
للعالم الا ترى ان هذا احد اسباب المشهد
الحالي اللي بنعيشه
الولايات المتحده لم تغادر العراق او لا
تزال تحقق وتوازن هاما في وجه النفوذ
الايراني
وهي هناك تدرب الجيش العراقي
وحققت بعض النجاح
من المفاجئ
ان العراق وضعه افضل من وضعيه افغانستان
اذا ما اخذنا من هذا الاعتبار ان التدخل
في العراق واجه صعوبات اكبر بكثير من
الصعوبات التي تواجهنا في افغانستان وفي
الحقيقه
اعتقد بان قرار غزو العراق في عام 2003
كان اكبر عائقا التي وجد تحقيق النجاح في
افغانستان اللي انا حول الانتباه هو
الموارد الاميركيه
الى اتجاه اخر فلا اعتقد بان امريكا
انسحبت من العراق ولم تنسحب ايضا من الشرق
الاوسط العراق خرج من حرب
ونستطيع الان
نشاكيك مثلا بضروره الحرب الحرب لم تكن
ضروريه على الاطلاق وربما غازونا البلاد
عن طريق الخطا وهذا ما سيذكره التاريخ
الدوله ونكتشف بعد اسابيع بان هذا الغزو
كان غير ضروري ا
لانه لم تكن هنالك اي اسلحه دمار الشامل
ولا حتى ارهابيين
بعد ذلك كانت هنالك سلوكيات متهوره
فلذلك اعتقد بان العراق
هو مثال عن
الاصرار والعزيمه في وجه الخصوم
ومن المدهش
كم حققته امريكا بعد كل هذه البدايه
السيئه